hello everyone welcome to my talk today
on value-based NLP I'm Pascal Fong
director of the center for AI research
at the Hong Kong University of Science
and Technology
I want to First give a a definition and
a common definition of some of these
terms that you have heard before
uh for example beneficial AI are AI
technology and systems that do good for
humans and the society ethics in AI are
actually different moral philosophical
principles that are pertinent to AI the
most famous example are asimov's three
laws of robotics which mandates that
robots should not do harm
ethics are sometimes called human values
there are different schools of moral
philosophy and different values
ethical AI technologies that are that
are designed to adhere to such ethical
principles
and it's also called the human value and
line AI
some example being I triple is ethically
aligned design uh being a document for
this responsible AI is the
operationalized version of ethical AI in
that uh in addition to alignment with
human values they also include adherence
to good engineering practices and good
product design principles today it is
commonly agreed that the core pillars of
Aria or transparency explainability user
agency and control robustness and safety
fairness inclusivity privacy and
security
so why do we need to do responsible AI
or why do we care care about human value
alignment uh major countries and
jurisdictions already have guidelines
and regulations for ethical and
responsible AI
academic and professional societies have
established ethical committees and
reviewing guidelines for research papers
public concern over the impact of AI has
led to over 100 published guidelines and
policies since 2017.
groups such as ISO and i2p are
publishing various industry standards
for AI governors
and for researchers Engineers the codes
of conducts of our professional
societies mandate that we build
technologies that that Do no harm
meanwhile there are a lot of Technical
and structural challenges
and yet the societal challenge presents
an opportunity for AI as a field to have
a new to have new research directions
approaches and measures
in time all AI should be responsible AI
so aligning human values with machines
or outlining machines with human values
the core challenges are twofold one is
what are these values and who defines
them second how can in this case NLP
algorithms in general AI algorithms and
models be made to align with these
values
um today I'm gonna make a very very
simple uh just talk about cases of
classification and generation
so first what are the desirable human
values and who defines them
a lot of organizations and governments
governments that have published lists of
ethical principles and standards
but we need to anticipate value depth
definition to be dynamic and
multi-disciplinary
we should separate the set of value
definitions as external to the
development of NLP algorithms or AI
algorithms
this will enable computer scientists to
work better with ethicist philosophers
and other humanists and we collaborate
with better that way
for example
large language models train from huge
amount of textual data are likely to
have come across such texts with value
definitions so we want to separate the
two
uh one reason being Engineers are not
the best people to Define human values
obviously
now human values are cultural dependent
and dynamic
a value such as women should be
protected by men is considered sexist
under the value of non-discrimination
but in some cultures this is considered
chivalry so it is a good value by those
cultures in those cultures and over time
cultures May evolve in the old days in
the western culture chivalry was
considered a good value today we have
advanced to non-discriminatory values
human values are multi-perspective
take the famous example of the trolley
problem the person can choose to divert
the trend from the main track saving
five people on the track killing the
worker on the other track should he or
she do make this choice
right so when you ask this question
people will have different answers even
attitudes were giving different answers
based on different uh perspectives human
values today can be described in natural
language this is why NLP plays a big
role so these are the ethical principles
by Chinese government and the EU and
they're described in natural language
in addition human values are
multi-dimensional let's take the example
of sexism there are different categories
of sexism ranging from Rose stereotyping
atrophone stereotyping body shaming all
the way to pay Gap
um hostile working environment and so on
and so forth
so now let's talk about large language
models
large pre-trained language models are
very powerful we know that
um they have become the foundation of
many NLP tasks ranging from
summarization machine translation to
conversational Ai and so on and so forth
because they are a powerful
representation of language and the
embedded knowledge
uh they can even be used to build NLP
applications by few short examples of
fine-tuning however they are still
uncontrollable non-transparent and
unstable if we use them as they are
so scaling also makes them more powerful
but the challenges remain and they can
cause unsafe output
to make them to make it desirable to use
these models for classification
generation we currently need to do some
pre-processing fun tuning or post
editing
there is no commercials use of
generative AI systems for example
because of the safety concern
now these ways of data processing or
detoxifying models or control Generation
all have their pitfalls ranging from you
know uh wrongful manipulation of the
data
and the manipulation of the model space
might render them more brittle
uh without fine-tuning certain
attributes you can you can you can do
control generation but values cannot be
you cannot easily be controlled in the
generation right they become
computational expensive
and post-processing is not a practical
solution especially in future
applications such as metaverse where
interaction is ephemeral real time
there's no no space or not time for
post-processing
so how do we align NLP systems with
defined values there are different
approaches that we have seen so far
there are uh mostly focused on
collecting data set from humans with
value targeted or value labels
um this kind of value uh labeled
collected from humans
um has two problems one they are costly
right
um you know 1.7 million examples human
judgments on everyday situations costs a
lot to collect and secondly
um this is done as part of a data
collection
um process
and that process is somehow not really a
principled approach to value definition
we assume that if we ask enough people
about what they think is right and wrong
we get the average moral Norm but it is
not a principal way of getting a value
definition so we propose externalize the
the the the choice of values and the uh
principle uh ethical approach uh from
the engineering of classifiers and
gender generation systems
here I'm going to show some case studies
these are by no means uh the definite
approach that we should take but the
initial approaches that we have
attempted and that have brought us some
good results and promising results that
um that points in the direction of um uh
separating value definition from value
alignment
so
um
so the first one is the human value
align generation so again let's use the
trolley problem it is ethical quandary
this question should we kill one person
to say five people in danger of being
hit by a trolley from the dental logical
perspective the answer is no from the
utilitarian perspective the answer is
yes because the principal says that we
should do the most good for the most
people
so answering these questions are
different from the normal NLP task of
question answering the uh NLP types of
question answered so far focused on
providing factual answers uh factoids
and clearances right
um here we're dealing with answers that
must come must consist of reasoning
itself
all right so the answer itself is uh
reasoning the risk itself is answer so
it's not just the final answer so we
want to build QA systems that
incorporates reasoning it also
incorporates reasoning according to
externally provided ethical principles
so here what do we do is in the first
step of this uh system it uh given a
question ethical question it looks for
Relevant principles relevant principles
uh from different ethical or moral
philosophies suffical schools and these
principles can come from uh
philosophical uh ethics books
um studies human experts or other
candidate pool so you can do this kind
of um ethical principle matching given
the ethical principle matching there in
the system will provide principal guided
answer so how does it come up with
principle got an answer we actually take
as ethical principles and prompt these
large language models for principle
guide and answer using future learning
however we do not use this kind of
prompting engineering as part of the
system we use that as a uh providing the
training data for us to go and and
fine-tune a downstream smaller language
model because the large language model
is is difficult to be fine-tuned right
it cannot be retrained every time we
have a new value so we just use these
values to prompt uh principal guided
answer from these last language models
and then we filter them
with confidence measure and then we use
this training data to fine-tune a
downstream uh qos model or language
models such as Bard and so on
so here uh some examples so for the uh
Charlie question the human selection is
a killing is not acceptable
um B the most appropriate action is the
one that achieves the greatest good for
the greatest number so suppose given
this human selection principles these
are the automatic automatic generator
sentences okay
um
and these are the automatic selection
I'm sorry the on the upper part are the
human selections on the bottom part are
the automatic selections
and then given the selections we will
generate uh uh um principal guided
answers here again
um given human principles these are the
generated answers
uh you can take a look because this is
recorded I think you can take a look at
these answers uh according to the
principles they're pretty good and this
is uh these are the answers according to
automatic generator principles again
take a look pause the video you can see
that these answers I'm not that coherent
as human answers and not always very
succinct but they do the job
so we then evaluate against human
generated answers human ethicist answers
and we see that wow our system can
provide multiple perspective reasoning
and answers to ethical quandary
questions so this is not another one of
those QA systems that that's just simply
based on Prom engineering it as actually
has the additional value in there
and the system can also compose cohere
analysis not as good as humans though
and it does provide justification to its
perspectives perspectives on the ethical
quandary so the key is that it does
provide principal guided answer it can
do reasoning
another experiment we have done is on
human value align classification
in this case uh we're trying to build a
classifier that classified as a case
study sexism so normally for sexism
classifier people just input a whole
bunch of rules and say these are classes
these are Sexes the classifier is
supposed to do its job or you provide a
lot of sexist
um examples and non-sexes examples and
the classifier learns and does its job
oh yeah the third approach you can
prompt the language models with future
learning and say this is success that's
not success and and and and see whether
it can learn
um whether it can then answer the
questions but that kind of problem based
um question answering or classification
are are not controllable so here we
propose uh another way again we're gonna
prompt these language models for
training data but in this training data
we have a more control so we actually
asked to uh the language model to
generate training data according to
different categories of sexism
and different categories of uh values
and counter values right
so here we have value one men and women
are equally capable for any role I give
you an example value two I give you
another example and uh and the language
model would then learn this and give
give me more uh uh more categories of
content or uh sexism and non-sex is
non-sexism instances and we use that to
fine-tune the classifier but in this
case the classifier has the additional
variable of value so depending on the
value it would classify input statement
as being sexist or not or uh not
applicable
okay so this is a training data
generation again you can pause the video
you can see the content
and here this is our
um our value align models are built to
maximize the likelihood of output given
the content and the model and also the
value
all right so this is our value aligned
classifier
all right according to different values
uh the classifier will give you a
different output
third part of my talk I would like to
talk about
um controlling hallucinations from
language language large language models
um in natural language generation we
have seen a lot of hallucinated content
they are
generated tax that is nonsensical
sometimes or unfaithful to the provider
Source input they can be uh revealing
sensitive personal information or
life-threatening when used in a medical
or medicine
um applications
and there are intrinsic as
hallucinations where they generate an
output contradicts The Source content
or extreme extrinsic hallucinations
where the generator output cannot be
verified from The Source content so
there are a problem for say machine
translation you have translated content
that can be biased that did not exist in
the source and uh there can also be
problems for summarizers uh where it
will hallucinate something that is not
in the source text right so how to
handle hallucination
moreover uh oh before I go on the this
is illustration of a problematic
language model hallucination
so we input one of long kinds of
symptoms is shortness of breath
uh on prompt 2 cancer can be prevented
by drinking too much alcohol
the generation then follows this kind of
the first one is factual uh sorry need
of which is factual but they will
continue to generate uh nonsensical and
uh unfactual
um statements which is not useful for um
which is actually um detrimental to our
application
let's not forget in visual language uh
domain Hallucination is also observed
for example here if you look at this if
you look at this um this is uh in visual
question answering when you look at the
screen what is this phone answer uh what
is on the phone screen the answer is a
text message from a friend so is looking
at a phone but it does not see any text
message but this natural language
hallucin um hallucinates this answer
from spurious correlations in language
models here again what do you see
outside the window well parking lot has
nothing to do with the picture
how by image captioning
so here it's a chest of drawers it says
the chest of drawers with a mirror on
top of it there is no mirror similarly
so models can hallucini answers given
the like uh the context of the text
but models can also hallucinate captions
with objects that are likely to occur in
the image space but these are all
hallucinated answers and they are not
correct
so coming back to natural language
generation contributions contributors to
hallucination improve from data
from training and inference again you
can pause the video and read this in
more detail
so what can we do to mitigate
hallucination there are many approaches
that people are attempting today none of
which is the definitive approach but
recently we've seen some progress
uh these are some of the common
medication methods from data related
methods to model and inference methods
pause the video you can see more
now I want to use one case study okay so
uh one of my main research areas a
conversational AI in conversational AI
once we move to neural networks
um and we use Bim search to generate um
sequence to sequence answers we found
that this beam search generates
repetitive and boring answers whereas
humans we tend to uh
tend to generate answers that are more
surprising with lower probability
therefore the approach of nuclear
sampling was proposed to recover the
human sampling process to take from Top
End vocabulary so saying that don't just
look at the most likelihood a most
likely answer from sequence to sequence
generation but also let's look at the
some kind of a sampling or random
sampling from the most likely
most likely vocabulary candidates so it
brings the surprise Factor back okay so
this has been applied to diversify convo
AI answers however the problem with that
is that the nuclear sampling will tend
to hallucinate and it will cause us to
have hallucinate more answers so
no nuclear sampling the answers can be
boring and repetitive with nuclear
sampling the answer can be more
Diversified yet it also has a higher
tendency to hallucinate answers so one
approach
um is to control the the nuclear
sampling by saying that at the beginning
of a sentence you're free to sample any
vocabulary but as you go down like uh
the sentence length right you're less
and less free to be surprising you do
have to be less surprising as you go
down so we'll just decrease the
threshold of nuclear sampling as we go
down so this is a very simple approach
it's called decaying p-value
right and uh we we set a lower bound and
then we set this decaying p-value
and if you look at the example here
um
so there's a problem so this is the
example here and then uh this is the uh
um uh factual uh prompt one of lung
cancer symptoms is shortness of breath
so if you use a greedy approach then the
answer just repeat it again and again
okay which is not good if you use
nuclear sampling it does not repeat the
answers but then it would hallucinate
answers they're not
not correct it says for example oxygen
mask to treat this devastating disease
that's for sureness of breath but has
nothing to do with lung cancer okay so
we don't like that with factual nuclear
sampling we control
we control the generation so that it's
less boring yet more factual so here you
see some kind of hallucination
hoarseness is not a very good uh example
but the rest is factual and also very
interesting
okay similarly uh the other example you
can read if you pause the video
so
um there are other uh future directions
in controlling hallucinations and here
are some of the uh design for metrics
and mitigation methods
in conclusion
human values are Dynamic cultural
contextual multi-dimensional and
multi-perspective
we need to decouple value definition
from value alignment Engineering in NLP
AI development large language models are
powerful but they're not controllable we
need to encapsulate them and preserve
their integrity or integrity
we propose to use them for augmented
training samples but to retrain a
smaller more controllable model
Downstream with human values as
additional conditions this can be
applied to both classification
generation tasks and so on
so this is my talk today and I hope I
hope that this inspires you to go on and
do more researching NLP and machine
learning with this new paradigm of human
value based AI because uh AI is a
technology that in that center around
humans and Society we cannot treat it as
a pure engineering exercise
but how to incorporate human values we
also cannot uh just randomly hardcore
human values without a principal guided
approach with atheists and uh and moral
philosophers with social scientists and
so on so this kind of approach enables
us to collaborate across disciplinary
across disciplinary
this kind of approach allows us to
collaborate across disciplines and also
with our society engaging the society as
a whole thank you very much